Hôm nay, 1 xong tháng 5, 2 ngày khu trăm 5, công an thành phố chiming lễ lễ 2 tại C C tại Lên quan đến vụ tên an xa thông, khiến một người từ vòng.
Thông tin ban đầu, chưa qua công an phường lông bình định được tin báo trên đường với sĩnh có vụ tên an xa thông, nên chỉ khai lực lượng đến thiện trường.
Tại đây, cạnh sát phát hiện người đàn ông nằm với đồng trên đường, cạnh đó là sẽ máy bị giữ tình đồng này.
Nát nhân nhé trong đường đường đường đến bình viện cấp cứu những gió vết thường của nó không qua khỏi.
Qua sát mình, nát nhân được xa định là ông nguyễn vình tế, bố mấy bà tuổi mụ tình đồng này.
Chích sức hình an người cơ mẹ ra và lễ lời khai nhân chứng, bố đầu công an xa định và khoảng 15 giờ bày phút nghiệm năm tháng 3,
xe máy sò ông tên đường phィền đã phát trạm với vình đôi xe tại trẻ cùng chíu.
Sau và trạm tại C C tại đã dưới khỏi hiện chíu, bằng các biệt pháp nghiệp vụ, tôi cùng ngay công an đám mời trên văn quyết, bố mấy tư tuổi, quay khoảng chi,
là người đường phィền xe tại đến chú sở làm việc.
Quái khai nhận là người đã đều phィền xe tại đến quan vụ tên an trên, hịt bố việc tức tục đuổi xa làm xó.